Dad, where do babies come from?
Well, there's a planet.
It's called Babylandia.
That's right, it's filled with babies,...
...babies of all kinds.
And when the time is just right, there's a space launch.
All systems go.
They wave goodbye, and then they board these big, shiny rocket ships.
Right?
They shoot off high in the sky,...
...and they fly through space, and then they penetrate the atmosphere.
And then they're released all over the place,...
...yeah, Africa and the Indian Ocean.
They were everywhere.
After an amazing nine-month journey, they find their mommies and daddies.
And that, son, is where babies come from.
But Jake said babies are made when mommies and daddies...
The wheels on the bus go round and round, round and round, round and round.
The wheels on the bus go round and round all through the town.